in this video i want to talk to you
about the growth uh that i had to go
through as an entrepreneur going from
zero to 85 million dollars a year um and
one of the things that i decided to stop
doing which is going home for the
holidays and i want to explain the
decision making process around this and
this comes from this is an older video
that i did
release into a smaller community and in
that group uh i can see the best
performing videos um and out of 300 plus
videos this is among the top uh
performing and so uh people seem to very
much like this and as we're going into
the holidays at least the time i'll me
posting this i thought it would be
timely but it really doesn't matter what
holiday uh you were you're celebrating
it's really a video about how to
navigate our pasts and use them to walk
with strength and conviction into the
future that we choose to create and a
lot of time it comes from shedding old
identities and learning how to unspeak
the things that were spoken over us in
our childhood from our parents from our
friends those who do not understand the
path that you're trying to go on as an
entrepreneur those who think that what
you're doing is stupid those who do like
who just don't believe um and at the end
of the day we need to believe and we
also need to create conditions that are
conducive to the goals that we have in
our lives and so this video gives you
the most tactical raw breakdown of how i
did it and i got so many people who told
me that the video changed their lives in
terms of how they approached uh their
pasts and the people and the
relationships that they maintain there
and how to protect their space
tactically in a way that will give you
the um the attention back to allocate
towards the things that matter so uh
moseynation uh i hope you enjoyed the
video like i said i i have nothing to
sell you this is just uh because i love
entrepreneurs and i want you to crush it
there's a lot of people who are broke
and i want you to be one of them see you
in the vid
good morning happy saturday i'm really
excited for this because i've actually
had this concept on my mind this piece
probably for the last two and a half
weeks so i feel like it's been like in
the back of my mind like percolating and
whatnot and it's combining with like
four or five other ones and i like felt
it this morning as i was eating
breakfast i was like all right today's
the day i'm gonna make it but recently i
wanted to call this why don't go home
for the holidays there's probably going
to be some things that i say that are a
little bit controversial but there are
things that have have absolutely
been some of the keys to our continued
growth and success
and i thought you might want to hear
them
and so i put the title as this for at
least for right now as success equals
ingrained intolerance so one of the
reasons that i don't go home for the
holidays is that a lot of people
haven't haven't grown since i left right
they they haven't had 10 years of growth
they've lived the same six months 20
times right since i was gone and when i
go back they want to meet me in my past
and so they want to speak things over me
that aren't who i am anymore and then
because it's difficult for them to
connect right the
their perception of who i used to be and
who the person is standing in front of
them how they are reconciled thank you
um
reconciling those two things is really
difficult for a lot of people because
it's breaking the box they want to put
you in but the reality is that most
people don't change
entrepreneurs do because we have to
right we call it growth instead of
change but for the outside world for the
non-entrepreneurs who stay in their same
box every day
it's it's it's hard to calculate and so
i'll go home and they'll say like my dad
says this he'll say
you have a you have the shortest views
out of anyone you just have such a short
temper anyone who is in our company my
wife like i mean
anyone who knows me and spends time with
me would probably not say that and so i
will be i mean very aggressive in
combating that immediately because i'll
be like don't speak that over me that's
not true that's not who i am
and it makes people really uncomfortable
and so there's a lot of times if i go
see an uncle you know what i mean if i'm
at a holiday event and then they're like
oh alexander you've always been a little
bit loose with the alcohol like
i don't even drink anymore you know what
i mean like you're speaking about my
past
and it makes people really uncomfortable
and
i would implore you to meet those things
head-on and the reason that i don't like
going home
for the holidays because i have to be on
guard
because when i when i leave i feel like
i have to like wash myself of the things
that people were trying to speak over me
and it's constant it's un it's unending
it's incessant right they're constantly
trying to put me back in the box that
makes sense to them i refuse to have
that happen and so when i have these
conversations it's it's passing comments
it's little things it's never because
most people aren't confrontational right
and so it's never oh like you are like
you don't mean like it's it's not like
that but it's just like oh you know how
you always are and they'll say it even
with like a smile like it's like it's a
good thing but like you have to catch it
because you know how it makes you feel
when you hear it you're like that's not
true that's not me
right i'm i'm done with that that's in
my past right and so like this is who i
am so i have to take like a week to
detangle and then basically re-speak
over the things that i am or that i
choose to be it's one of the main
reasons that i don't go back for the
holidays and i really really don't like
it
and i definitely don't like spending any
portion of extended time there is
because it feels like i'm going
backwards you know what we are all as a
community trying to accomplish is not
normal and we just have to
come to terms with the fact that it
isn't normal it's okay that it's not
normal but it also means that normal
people aren't gonna like it the higher
up we go in business i think at least
this is just my subjective understanding
of how i'm how i'm perceiving it as i go
through it the more intolerant we become
of people who try and
i mean it's even tones like i'll be like
don't speak to me in that tone
even if they're saying that i think i'm
like it seems disrespectful it bothers
me and like you become more and more
aware because you're like let me teach
you how to treat me
right and sometimes you have to do that
and especially when it's been a long
period of time you have to teach people
how you like to be treated now and a lot
of times it's a lot different than it
was when they first met you right and
it's the hardest with family because
i'll be really real with you there's a
lot of people that i'm connected with
that i probably would never see again if
i didn't have a blood relation i manage
our space very well if we you know if we
go back it's only going to be for a
short period of time because there's no
other reason besides the fact that we
share a biological bond that i would
ever see you again because you haven't
you don't have the same goals you don't
have the same values you don't want to
do the things i want to do when we see
each other you make me feel worse
why would i see you right i'm just being
very real with you guys and maybe this
is something that i'll look back at this
video
five years from now and i'll have grown
more and i'll have more perspective but
that's that's where we are now being so
intolerant of this stuff is like is so
key to being able to like grow i'm
telling you because and that's why
that's why there's just we keep such
quiet space right because it's like the
only place that you don't have to have
your guard up constantly fending off
what other people are trying to tell you
about yourself
right and so you can kind of build it
while it's while it's in its infancy and
you're not as strong yet in these new
attributes that you're trying to have i
was talking to
a high-level entrepreneur uh yesterday
who's like ah i mean i'm just horrible
at details and i was like don't speak
that over yourself i was like because
your business might need you to be good
at details when you go from 10 to 20
million don't say that
and he was like you're right i was like
yeah you choose you're choosing to not
be good at details do you really think
that if your kids were going to die like
because you needed to learn to remember
things to be able to do it like well
yeah i'm like all right then you're
choosing to not be good at it that's
your choice that's your belief right and
so like if you identify these things
like
man i'm getting really deep on this i
know but like the identity is so fluid
we can change
in an instant like tony robbins talks
about this stuff all the time like the
only moment that we're actually able to
live in is right now right and so all of
the things that we had before us are
only stories that we can either choose
to replay because they're positive
attributes or choose to ignore if
they're negative attributes and a lot of
us just stay in these loops of of
speaking these these things over
ourselves that don't even serve us
right one of my favorite sayings in the
world probably one of my favorites like
one of the most profound sayings is
we question all of our beliefs except
for those that we truly believe and
those we never question at all
and i always i love that because it just
makes you aware of like i love catching
myself on a belief that i've always had
that i believe so thoroughly that i
never actually thought to question it
because that's how much i believed it
right it's just been there and so like
the higher up we go the more we kind of
uncover these beliefs about what's
possible what can we do how can we grow
how quickly can change happen you look
at our business right like
we pivoted from a done 40 model to the
done with you model that we have now in
april of 2017 right
and so from april of 2017 until today
right that's like 19 months i think
right we've gone from zero to
arguably the biggest company in fitness
like in in the brick and mortar gym
fitness world and we're like two or
three times the size of anyone else
who's like the second runner up 2019
we're gonna probably three to four x
that i can say that pretty with a lot of
certainty
and so like how quickly are you able to
achieve what you want to achieve is it
supposed to take a year because you're
choosing to believe that it's supposed
to take a year how quickly can you
onboard someone let me give you another
story we're about to do a very big
launch for our legacy group i can't tell
you what it is but a friend of mine
launched a new service category in his
business and it blew up overnight he had
a huge explosion of traffic he was
running like some ads and they just took
off right he couldn't do anything about
it
and so he hired
30 people in 14 days for his customer
service team 30 people in 14 days and so
when we had our q4 planning right our
fourth quarter planning we had our
customer service director and i and lily
i love you to death it has nothing to do
but like this was what happened during
the during the actual meeting she was
like i feel comfortable saying that i
can bring four people on every month
between now and ex-launch date right
which would you know get us to probably
16 or so people 16 to 20 right by the
launch date which is gonna be like three
or four months away and so then i told
that story about my friend who had just
done this he hired 30 people in 14 days
because he had to and so a lot of times
the necessity is one of the biggest
things that allows us to break our
beliefs because we have to we have no
other choice and that's why when we have
scripts and whatnot and the the show
rates double based on the fact that you
know you actually are going to leave a
location and you're not going to be able
to sell that person the tonality of how
you're speaking to the prospect even
though the words are the same
the fact that it's just what you believe
that changes the outcome and the
influence on the other person is like so
cool to me and so the question is like
how can we trick ourselves into
believing what we need to believe in
order to grow faster i did this
experiment you know three years ago
where i put on like 35 pounds of muscle
in six weeks right and i started and
they asked me to write an article it's
muscle and strength and i did it natural
you can choose to believe me or not but
i did it wasn't their five pounds of
muscle but it was 35 pounds and a lot of
it was muscle um
within six weeks and i started the
article off by saying like what if you
actually had to gain 35 pounds in six
weeks and get and add 100 pounds to your
batch what would you do and so i tried
to put this conf like these confines on
myself and i was like i probably
wouldn't just lift one you know twice a
week right for that lift i'd probably
lift it like once or twice a day
and then that's what i did and then i
got really really strong really fast i
added 100 pounds to my pitch in six
weeks and i was natural right and i did
that because of the confine like the
confines that we put ourselves under and
so sometimes i wonder like
what things are we allowing to be spoken
over ourselves by others first
and then second what things are we
speaking over ourselves that we don't
even know that we're doing constantly
questioning like those things that we
speak over ourselves has been honestly
one of the biggest things that has
allowed us to grow i know that i haven't
been as tactical in the last few content
videos i hope you guys don't mind um
it's just been what's on my mind um we
had chris and rob and barnett who flew
out here because they won a competition
that we were holding in secret
anyway so chris and robin barnett came
out
and they were like we feel like we're
stuck right we feel like we're in a
bottleneck and like we just can't we're
just trying to break through
and um when i talked to them about it i
um
the whole time they were here for the
whole day
i didn't tell them a single tactical
thing to do differently with their
business not one
but what we identified was the things
that they were speaking over themselves
and the things that they were choosing
to believe about how quickly things can
happen right and so i'll give you an
example i hope they don't mind robin his
chris's wife didn't want to be in the
gym anymore she's like it's not my
passion you know like i cut like now
we're comfortable like i kind of want to
do my own thing
and so
um and it was causing some strife in
their relationship mostly because like
you know
she felt you know betrothed to him that
she had to keep doing it but then he
felt guilty that she know what i mean
there's just kind of both sides of it
right
um and so they were like well we're
gonna let robin go you know she's gonna
leave in four months right so we're
gonna get four months um and then she'll
get out of the business and i was like
why didn't she just get out today
like she doesn't want to do it you don't
want her there
like why don't you just get out today
like why are you choosing to believe
that it needs to take four months you
know like i guess it doesn't i was like
right
and so a lot of times like i've just
this has just been recently for me i've
had
a lot of conversations with guys who are
doing five to 12 million a year in their
businesses and a lot of them have been
doing this a lot longer than me and
they're like how have you freaking grown
so if like how are you hitting the
numbers you're hitting how is the growth
rate that you guys are having like how
is it possible right
and like we've really just like
i've tried not to be weird about this
but like we've just chosen to believe
it's possible we've really just chosen
to believe it's possible and a lot of
times like if you talk to them and it's
like you see these guys who are really
really really high up in the business
world a lot of times they do talk very
non-tactical very much mindset stuff
and i think it's and i used to really
not appreciate it but now i think i'm
appreciating it a little bit more
because the reason that a lot of people
aren't successful is because of the
beliefs that they have because if you
can remove and break those beliefs a lot
of times they will go find the tactics
that are necessary right to win and the
higher up you go the hot like the
cleaner people keep their space and the
reason they do that the reason they keep
it so quiet is so that they can pinpoint
anything that comes in their area right
anything that's gonna break or ch chip
at them or just like bother them in any
way to keep this bubble around them and
then what that does though is that it
gives them such clean perspective and
clean vision on what's going on because
a lot of times when i have these guys
like i said you were doing you know five
six ten million a year and they're like
what's going on it becomes really
obvious it's really it's it's really
apparent i'll give you another example i
had yesterday i talked to a guy who's
doing um he's doing half a million a
month right now and he has it split
between two businesses he's got one
business does like 400 000 a month he's
got one that does a a hundred thousand a
month and he's like well the big you
know the 400 000 a month business is my
old business um it's the one that it's
it's got all the complexity in it i hate
the customers
all this stuff right
and then he's like and then this
business is really simple it's super
profitable i'm running like three times
the margin i run in that business
and um
and he's like so i just i
just can't figure out how to grow
and i was like do you really can't
figure out how to grow
he's like yeah just like i got so much
stuff going on and i was like yeah you
should probably just get rid of the
thing that is a big headache for you and
do the thing that you really like doing
i was like do you think if you got rid
of all of the attention that that 400
000 month thing is sucking up you'd be
able to double the hundred thousand one
thing he's like yeah like easy and i was
like cool then why don't you do that
right and it becomes really apparent and
obvious to you on the outside like i
mean these guys aren't dumb you know
what i mean he's doing 6 million like
he's not stupid it's just the beliefs
that we truly believe are the ones that
we don't see and so it's really
interesting and like i think all the
time like i want to be wiser i want to
have more discernment and if you really
if you start to dissect like what is
wisdom right
wisdom is being able to see is if two
people are looking at the same situation
the wiser person sees things that the
other person doesn't and so it's it's
vision it's being able to see what other
people don't see
and a lot of times they're just unseen
chains that people have already chosen
to tie themselves up with
right and we're having
a lot of gemini's i've had just recently
a string of gym owners stopping like man
we're just stuck at 60 000 a month like
i don't know what this bottleneck is and
i always respond i'm like it's not the
business model right it's you
and it's and it's and i should probably
respond more specifically it's a belief
that you have that you haven't
identified yet
that's holding you back a lot of times
it's just because you're choosing to
make less money
like no joke a lot of people choose to
make less money so people like we have
gym owners right now who are asked like
hey like
i've got this campaign it's crushing it
i think i'm going to turn it off for
next month right because like we have a
lot going on i'm like if you want to
choose to make less money that's your
choice you know and so we make these
choices if you if you were to articulate
them differently you'd probably think
they were ridiculous and i had every
conversation i've had just in the last
two weeks i've talked to four
entrepreneurs last two weeks they were
doing five million or more per year and
each one of the conversations ended with
like well when you put it like that i
sound like an idiot and i was like well
are you it's like well no and i was like
then you should probably change the way
you're doing it and so it's just these
emotions and these beliefs that get in
our way of like what is seems so obvious
and it's just because some we are
emotional beings right we are we make
decisions with emotions and we try and
logic it later but when you look at
things logically a lot of times some of
the the answers are obvious well i've
got this trainer that i've had for two
years but they're such a pain they never
want to do anything of the anything
that's new but i have some clients that
that still like them okay do you think
that if you had a new trainer that was
like bought in
that you would be able to grow more
so what it is is the fear of losing
these few clients that are attached to
this one trainer is outweighing the
potential growth you would have from the
key player that you know you need in
order to make the model work and then
when it's phrased that way it becomes
obvious yeah i gotta let them go but you
don't have the perspective yet until
sometimes you just need someone on the
outside but anyways guys um thank you
for spending saturday morning with me
this was just something that was on my
mind and i just like it was like
stirring in me but be mindful of the
things that speak people speak over you
and the tone that they do it and just
like if you feel weird after someone
says something
stop the conversation catch it and then
address it and be like please don't
speak to me like that please don't say
those things about me it really bothers
me i'm really working on this or i've
worked a lot on this and i don't i don't
appreciate it
it really bothers me
and if that person cares about you they
will change and if they don't get them
out of your life you don't need that and
the most important person to make sure
that you're doing that with is you
like if you're the one who's saying man
i'm just not good at details man i'm
just i'm just i hate employees
good luck running a business these are
things i overhear even in our group like
ah employees are idiots i'm like do you
really think that that is a good belief
to grow and repeat inside of yourself if
you want to grow and scale a business
probably not
right
like be mindful of the things that
you're saying because and then ask
yourself like does this belief serve
and if it doesn't get rid of it so
anyways i hope you guys have an amazing
weekend um i love you all thank you guys
for
for for giving me your attention i know
it's your most valuable resource so
thank you i hope i gave you a good
return on it
and i hope you guys have an amazing
amazing day all right lots of love bye